cody and i've been having such a rough
time for so long it's really hard to be
in a room with everybody and watch him
be incredible in other relationships and
know that your own is terrible nine
months after sister wife star christine
brown left her 25-year plural marriage
to cody
she's making it clear she's done with
polygamy
the message that we had to the world
about functional
polygamy
seems so dysfunctional now
christine tells people she's putting
that lifestyle behind her quote i will
be a monogamist from here on out
polygamy is not for me anymore people
can do it it's fine live your life but
no no not me i like my own space i like
my own autonomy i feel like i like me
better now as and i just feel like i've
been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to
the reality star married cody in 1994
becoming his third wife after mary and
janelle
his fourth wife robin joined the
marriage in 2010.
bringing somebody new into the family is
a totally new thing totally changing the
dynamic and is a really big deal cody's
my soul mate
i love him
[Music]
how's it going
christine says of the relationship it
was crowded but we had so much fun
together and notes that she only wanted
a polygamous marriage since that's how
she was raised
but things have changed and christine's
ready to try something new
quote i started thinking maybe this
isn't working for me and then i stopped
believing in polygamy i realized i
didn't really want to live it anymore i
didn't like sharing a husband or feeling
like i wasn't important
i've decided to leave i'm going to leave
cody
i agreed to be a sister wife but i
agreed to be an equal
wife and now christine's doing what's
best for her she says quote i get to
live life for me my whole world has
changed and every single cell in my body
is happier i really have more of an
independence when it comes to a future
partner christine knows exactly what she
wants
i want a guy who actually loves me and
wants to be with me intimately the
attraction needs to be there there needs
to be a mutual chemistry but i love the
idea of a romantic relationship
[Music]
you